Oh guys get out of here spoiler alert
hey guys it is time for my February
favourites these are some of the things
that I've really been enjoying this
month because you care I can't even look
at you and I said this I've been up in
Canada been in a hotel room so a lot of
my favorites are small size it's not the
size that counts it's how much it's
worth
first these PCC yeah these are travel
bag things for other small things I got
these at Victoria's Secret
what I know what was I doing in there
they let me in they had no idea these
were two for $34 which I thought was a
great deal you only have makeup bagging
it's so dirty and then you feel like
it's a reflection of your life I love to
buy a new makeup bags and transfer all
my products over so I just feel like I'm
cleaner I don't love that it just says
the name Victoria's Secret so big on it
but it is sort of subtle so that's okay
and this one how it makes a statement I
also don't like that it says Victoria
Secret but hey if you hold it like this
which is normal to hold a bag like this
look how normal that is this bag caused
me and the cashier lady to have a
conversation because she said she like
this very much and I said thank you what
are you doing that moment when you're
buying something at the store and the
person that's ringing you up says they
like what you're buying they compliment
it you say thank you as if it's already
yours you haven't made the full
transaction yet you don't own that item
it's still that store site you know you
can't say thank you on behalf of the
item sperry life sucks now the rest of
my favourites are inside of these things
ask you CFC Sam Rimmel London stay matte
liquid mousse foundation words and words
and words and words this was a cheap
drugstore foundation I got when I got up
here and it does exactly what it says it
does it stays mat like me in a
confrontation I stay matte doormat next
this you see I see I see
this is Smashbox photo finish foundation
primer I never really believed in
primers I thought it was like a made-up
thing that the makeup industry created
to get us to buy another product the
same way that I did
your washing machines needed to be
cleaned so they made a product for you
to clean your washing machines
commercialism mo right I've realized
that this actually works very well it
keeps my foundation lasting much longer
and it keeps it from getting super shiny
I have a lot of red undertones in my
face
and my skin gets red really easily it's
very sensitive to light and this one is
a green which counteracts read but east
when you put it on it's so translucent
you don't even see green unless you're
just a jealous person by Nature
next that you see she's had this product
I chose for this favorites video because
one half I love it and one half I don't
know how it works this is a two full
product boop-boop-boop double-ended
dildo for your eyelashes Tarte lights
camera lashes mascara on one side which
is one of my favorite mascaras and they
have really cute pony names lights
camera lashes they also have one called
something else with a pun and then the
other half of this is called best info
it says that it is lash extending fibers
it's not a mascara it's just these weird
like fibrous things what do I do with
this internet help it's too much work
for me to just type into Google so I
thought I'd make a whole video just as a
purpose to get you guys to tell me what
I knew what with this next that you say
oh yeah this is a Clinique like lip
thing it came in a pack of three one is
a super bomb chubby stick nothing I like
putting on my mouth more than a chubby
stick and this is like the whatever that
is and goes on your mouth it looks way
darker than it actually goes on see I'm
wearing it today
this one's called black honey this one's
called black honey and then the chubby
stick is called Richard raisin why not
next yeah you say how can you say yeah
he's here this is for a Williams girl
pretty grants here's the thing I love
fro Williams I think it's a very
attractive human being I also think he's
a very smart savvy businessman and I
think he might be secretly the world's
greatest comedian and now he makes this
set that's supposed to be for men and
women which are my favorite since when
it's not just overtly oh I sprayed that
directly into you and not onto me oh why
did I spray
my shoulder arm anyway it smells was it
smell like it smells like what is this
smell like this smells like like like
like cucumber something next these yeah
okay yeah it's no surprise to any of you
but maybe it's a surprise to new people
hi I love sweatpants so goddamn much I
just got these at Zara $29 you can tell
that I like them so much I have a warm
yet sweatpants just want to remind you
guys how much I love sweatpants neck can
you see it can you see okay so you can't
see it because it's more of a concept
rather than a thing my other favorite
for the month is putting my clothes and
drawers in a hotel room I just started
putting my stuff in the drawers in this
hotel room and it's been a great time
did that change your life okay that's it
for my favorites video I hope that you
enjoyed it and you liked any of these
products maybe they inspire you to do
something in your life that isn't what
you're doing right now but also don't
stop what you're doing right now and you
don't have to stop if you subscribe and
click like for the video so that I can
know that this made something happen for
you
I don't know next can you hear it can
you hear it
can you hear
one of my favorites this month is safety